now hopefully we've got to return to the
leader at the House of Commons Jacob
Riis more can see their excellent news
and we were talking about the
possibility of a brexit deal and I just
want to see if I can get a bit of
clarity from you on what the government
is looking at and I know that of course
we're just working on reports at the
minute but what we're seeing appears to
be the UK including Northern Ireland
leaving the customs union but Northern
Ireland's continuing to follow some of
the rules some of the tariffs set by the
EU however Northern Ireland would
potentially be involved in future trade
deals and business could get refunds
with UK tariffs were lower is that
roughly the right ballpark but we'll
have to wait and see what the precise
details are naturally in the middle of a
negotiation these matters are extremely
sensitive because everybody is
compromising to some degree and
therefore to give the negotiations the
best chance of succeeding it's best to
be discreet about them I can tell you
that the cabinet will be briefed at
12:45 this afternoon as to how far these
negotiations have gone and that's
obviously an important part of the
process because collective
responsibility requires that and we will
see more details emerge over the next
few days okay I'll have to wait and see
for some of them on it you're not
exactly telling me that anything is
wrong at the same time and I can't help
thinking that the plan sounds a little
bit similar to the customs partnership
put forward by two recently last year
now that of course was a plan that you
described at the time is completely
cretinous impractical
bureaucratic and a betrayal of common
sense so if you change what well I don't
know whether you're right or wrong so
we'll have to find out in a day or two
whether I will have to eat my words or
not time will tell so you are thinking
that you might have to eat your words
then so what's changed I don't I don't I
I don't know but there's a line from
Churchill saying it often had to eat his
own words and he'd find it found it to
be a very nourishing diet and that is
something that happens in politics but
it is ultimately a question of trust
about the direction in which we are
going to go back to what we were
discussing before we were interrupted by
the gremlin
that I trust Boris Johnson to ensure
that the relationship the UK has with
the European Union is one well where we
are not a vassal state and that is the
point that we are leading towards in all
these discussions and I'm very keen that
we should succeed in getting to you say
you trust Boris Johnson is it just
because you've got a bit of a better job
this time no certainly not
I've trusted Boris Johnson long before
you asked me to form be part of the
government he formed so know that an
irrelevance and I don't want to ask a
question that I did actually asked last
time but as you say the gremlins
slightly got in the way and you've been
writing this morning talking about the
potential need for compromise what
compromises are you prepared to make ah
yes I'm sorry you didn't get that on so
what I said then was that we've already
made compromises that if you look at the
House of Lords report from 2017 we don't
know the EU any money if we leave
without a deal
so the 39 billion is not aid under
international UK or EU law and that's a
pretty big compromise to be willing to
give thirty-nine billion pounds of
taxpayers money to the European Union to
secure deal so there are already many
compromises that people have been
willing to make people like me people
like the Prime Minister in order to
ensure a smooth exit with a decent deal
so you're effectively saying that and
the rest of the withdrawal agreement is
something that you might be able to
swallow at the end of this process are
we in control of our law if we are in
control of our law then we will have
left the European Union properly the
problem with the previous deal was that
under the backstop we potentially were
never going to be in control of our law
and therefore we would have remained the
vassal state so that's my key arguments
why people can trust the Prime Minister
we will not be a vassal state at the end
of this process we will have left
cleanly we will be in control of our
laws and that's crucial because that is
a genuine brexit rather than brexit in
name only any deal of course has got to
get passed Parliament and one body of
people in Parliament he may be asked to
make some pretty big compromises are the
DEP
their Westminster leader Nigel Dodd said
yesterday that Northern Ireland has to
remain fully part of the customs union
and that a double custom solution like
the one we've been hearing about cannot
work other DEP actually are bored with
this well you'll have to ask the DUP
what their position is but I am a member
of the conservative and unionist party
the United Kingdom is of great
importance to conservatives and that
obviously includes Northern Ireland as
an integral part of it and the Prime
Minister has made himself Minister for
the Union and is deeply personally
committed to ensuring that the union is
robust and prospers and I don't believe
the Prime Minister would do anything
that would undermine the integrity of
the United Kingdom we know of course how
strongly you feel about this particular
subject because you've told us before in
March this year you said I'm strongly
influencing guided by the DDPs concerns
about the Union my only condition is the
position of the DEP I won't abandon the
DEP because I think they are the
guardians of the Union so if the DEP
cannot back any deal that Boris Johnson
brings back will you then resign and
vote against it well I think this is
extremely premature that we don't know
the details of the deal we don't know
the dup s position and we don't know how
we received in the country at large so
we've got to see how the DUP react to
things when we know them as fact
radner's speculation but the United
Kingdom is of great importance to
conservatives and the Prime Minister has
made it clear that the United Kingdom
will remain a single customs territory
and that Northern Ireland will remain
within the UK customs union he's been
absolutely explicit about that but it's
fair to say that the DP position is one
of extreme importance to you the deepest
position is of importance to the British
nation because the Good Friday Belfast
agreement requires the principle of
consent to any change to the
constitutional position of Northern
Ireland from both communities the DUP is
an important representative of the
unionist community and if you are to
make a change in Northern Ireland's
constitutional position in any way it
would require the consent of both
communities say it's not whether it's
important to me or not it's in
Orton to the whole nation we're running
out of time to be frank and if we are to
hit that October 31st deadline
absolutely everything has got to go
right
could you countenance a short delay or
extension if it meant getting press over
the line well if we get the deal and we
have a vote possibly next Saturday and
that is agreed getting it through in
legislation won't be that problematic
and bear in mind we could deal with the
application of a king emperor within 24
hours we can therefore deal with leaving
the European Empire within 12 days but
would a few extra days be a problem in
theory the Prime Minister has been
absolutely clear we are leaving on the
3rd 1st of October this is of great
importance
so no extension under any circumstances
look I mean you've heard what the Prime
Minister has said he is not going to
Europe to ask for an extension he's
going to say shall we do this deal or
shall we leave without a deal and - and
see where that goes that endless
extensions are not doing us any good
they're not solving the problem and we
saw I mean you may have thought my
reference 1936 was a bit antiquated but
the ban brackets surrender bill act got
through in a few days
Parliament can legislate quickly when it
needs to and the big decision will be
the meaningful vote oh how you seen the
surrender bill there and you know there
has been a lot of criticism hasn't there
about some of the loaded language that's
been used in the debate and I know that
you have no personally had you know
abuse that yourself and your family
don't you think we need to be a bit more
careful with our language in this I
think the argument about the surrender
bill is completely bogus actually that
using terms that encapsulate the purpose
of an act is completely normal and
standard and politicians all do this
so the Socialists called the community
charge the poll tax because they wanted
to get a political point across and it's
very important to differentiate that
from the type of abuse that people get
on social media of threats of violence
and of deep hatred and I know this
particularly happens to lady
broadcasters so I know this is a serious
problem but it's entirely
different from using political terms in
relation to what other politicians are
doing the drama McDonald's line about
esta McVeigh being lynched is a quite
disgraceful thing to have said and is
something that should be stopped simply
shouldn't happen but so calling
something a surrender bill is just the
normal use of language and now there are
a couple of there are things I'm keen to
talk to you about while we have you as
well I'm sure you've heard the case of
how done the teenager killed in a road
accident by a woman who married to a
diplomat has now left the UK and gone
back to the u.s. we've learned today
from the Foreign Office that they don't
consider her to have diplomatic immunity
does that mean that in your opinion she
should now return to the UK and
potentially face justice well I was
listening to Sky News earlier on this
morning before coming on and saw your
report of what the Foreign Office has
said and the Foreign Office has said
that it's now a matter for the police
and the prosecution service to determine
what should happen next but I think what
has been announced today is important
and one has just such sympathy for the
Dunn family that nothing is worse than
the loss of a child and then to find
somebody is able to use diplomatic
immunity to leave the country must have
been the bitterest blow and I'm glad
that developments are happening that
appear to be going in the right
direction and just finally we've seen
some renewed problems in Syria with
Kurdish forces coming under bombardment
from Turkey are you worried that Kurdish
fighters are now being apparently
abandoned by some of their former allies
in the US and also potentially the UK
well the government is concerned about
what has happened and of course Turkey
is a important NATO ally and the
government is discouraging turkey from
taking this action as is the United
States and it is really in the hands of
the Turkish authorities and the
government will continue to press them
too
stop doing this of course there is worry
for many of the communities in Syria and
the real effort must be to defeat - and
to prevent that terrorist cause having
any further strength ok Jake every small
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning thank you as well
--shoes